[Music]
there is nothing wrong with your
computer do not attempt to adjust your
monitor we are controlling the video if
we wish to annoy you will add obnoxious
pappa bands if we wish to infuriate you
we will load the video even slower so
that all you can see is the annoying
circle if we wish to confuse you we will
satirise a show that was popular in the
60s but you'll still kind of get because
you saw it on that Simpsons Halloween
special for the next half hour sit
quietly and we will control all that you
see and hear you are about to experience
the awe and mystery of nostalgic
commercials they're back and they're
ready to sell you their shit nostalgic
Saturday morning commercials are
practically a lost art in that there's
no more Saturday morning cartoons to
play them with thanks non-stop kids
floatation media but nevertheless there
was still a strange otherworldly feel to
the ads of the 80s and 90s and even some
more recent ones too so today we're
gonna take a look at their bright
colorful sugar-coated brain cell killing
awesomeness in all its glory
because commercials are reviewable too
what makes them memorable what makes
them laughable now what makes them
memorably laughable so seeing how they
call the first one after these messages
the second one we'll be right back the
third one explanation point then the
fourth one the fourth one this one I'm
calling the quickening
[Applause]
now kids come together yeah you all know
this one
go ahead and sing
[Music]
this is the classic ad for a toy house
pretty much just jump rope for a
disposable income wow that is the best
thing of all remember when you had to
count look at the fucking terrible days
when you actually had to count
not only do I get to stay in just one
place for hours but I get to not think
of numbers while doing it
this thing's the new iPhone 6 as much as
I love this ad have you ever known
anyone that was good at it I mean
fucking anyone I sure didn't nobody I
knew could ever get the hang of this
damn thing if they really want to get it
right they will parotitis it like this
hey kids see the new toy in town to get
you more a queen with the ground it's
true--but jaded smashing faces into a
sports trip it trip it to the toy bread
it's their fault because the perfect
thing of all the numbers on the phone
maybe
little fuckers onto a very short trip it
TripIt shrimp it's a lawsuit waiting to
happen
well it still a catchy song that won't
be leaving anytime soon so there's the
strange period of time when the
crash-test dummies which were originally
PSA is for a seatbelt safety got their
own toys made it was weird there was
like an evil dummy who wanted to stop
their crashing because that was a thing
I guess but in theory it was still kind
of cool because it was the only toy you
were expected to break even though every
commercial ended with the same line
don't be a dummy it's a little ironic
that you're learning about car safety by
being encouraged to crash a car this is
actually kind of sick yeah maybe that
one went through the windshield or that
one's fucking bleeding to death innocent
fun maybe I'm reading too deep into it I
mean after all it's not like there was a
torture chair to live out your sadistic
fantasies crushing Bank pickles
[Music]
what does any of this have to do with
car safety okay
there's playful violence and then
there's saw this is all waters better it
really think I'm beating whatever what
that part of our brains like this it was
a hit for a while even if we should
probably be concerned why don't you feel
your safety about or I'll kill you
[Music]
I'm the melting ass animatronics from
Ninja Turtles three God how did they go
from Jim Henson puppetry to a dead-eyed
courts with fish and wine pulled lips
like mister end in football TV tossing
Leo's making sure the foot aren't having
a ball actually the funny thing is you
can tell this is one they were running
out of ideas for stuff to put the Ninja
Turtles on in the early 90s they were
literally on everything no I mean fuckin
everything like lively things back low
fat yogurt so it's pretty obvious this
is when we were getting to the point
where they had very few options left
friends are you in the market for a new
car mics Cowabunga surf buggy welcome
back to the International turtle game I
just love the Old West it's kinda like
saying remember when Batman took a
baseball or Wonder Woman took up bowling
okay those were actually real things but
it still feels wrong it's crazy clapping
bye
leader of the turtle tribe Bandido
bustin white it's wrapped the
Magnificent hey the rapid pops but wait
there's war
uh-uh there's ninja turtles accounting
ninja turtle Tollbooth operator and last
but not least pregnant ninja turtles
like preggers Bunga things weren't going
too well okay we swear it's all part of
the original source material practically
nothing has changed
it's not just an attempt to have you buy
it as a gift or something chases turtles
just what I've always wanted
[Music]
enjoy our fumes all yours for no money
down no installments you just paid for
it we're out of ideas oh my god this may
be the greatest bumper for anything ever
okay so you're about to watch something
on HBO what do you usually see before it
starts fucking riveting you want to see
what they had back in the 80s
[Music]
but whimsical whimsy of wonderment is
this
[Music]
by God it feels like I'm flying over a
model of micromachines butts don't like
the music just keeps getting bigger and
bigger what's magical realm are we being
transported to me
[Music]
yes yes
cause nowhere else will you find
ingenious entertainment mixed in with
pointless boom shot
wait a minute could there be something
even more masculine vo
[Music]
[Applause]
fucking amazing I mean fucking amazing
what would you rather watch before it's
seeing anything
this we're incredible I guess uh or
flying like fucking Peter Pan to a
Godzilla model of wonder HBO you gotta
bring this back I don't care if you have
to throw in Tyrion Lannister or
something just for God's sakes bring
this back even if the movie are showing
his goddamn Jack and Jill it'll be a
little bit better
[Music]
yeah
ah I don't think that's how that works
was this like the missing line that
Rocky's coach used to say yeah gotta
drink water and crap me yummy want me
delicious cha listen girls and wigs I
just think you're kind of giving kids
the wrong idea I mean what if a parent
is like oh somebody needs their diaper
change
no I've been waiting for this for so ya
[Applause]
know just just know just know I'm Polly
Pocket wanna see what's new Polly Pocket
wasn't this ingenious
it's a tiny girl who lives in the world
that's also a compact good Jesus
that's like the ultimate combination of
girl toys it's dolls doll houses and
makeup all rolled into one
it's the ultimate trifecta you'll be
vomiting pink for a week Polly Pocket
nothing really wrong with these now that
I'm looking back at them growing up but
being a boy back then of course hated
watching these commercials I mean
they're just so girly
what they even do you open up this
little world and walk through it and
then close it up to carry it around or
frigging it now boys we of course had a
lot better like Mighty Max Spidey man
hell yeah this was completely different
and so much better you open up this
little world walk for it and then close
it up to carry it around a million times
more advanced that probably missing
pockets just look at how into what this
kid is getting it's a little fucking
psycho watch watch out for that first
step it's not my max get fried his fate
is in your hands that butterfly whose
wings I was going to pull off each sold
separately money max figure included
from Mattel but he'll that wasn't the
end of it we had other super masculine
toys back then like oh well if it's just
an oven I don't know yes before
everything was after everything was
super but they meant totally different
things and don't you forget and now you
can make your own wide open Power
Rangers Oh
to be fair they look less like Power
Rangers and more like skinless human
beings who got White House built on them
but he captured the non-existent
personalities pretty good
[Music]
yeah now that's how you do a boy's toy
there isn't any girls toy out there
that's even remotely
well our version was better we couldn't
eat ours and live you know begin to
think boys toys were just girls toys
painted a different color and given less
objects feel so huge nilly think they
have an exact center comes with
everything you see here like not
included oh yeah can't forgive this one
around the holidays a little snowman
comes in and gets warmed up to a bowl of
Campbell's soup only to reveal it was
actually little boy the whole time
nothing melts away the cold like a
delicious cold of Campbell's soup okay
concept and all but my biggest question
is fuck look there kid outside so long
that he would become a snowman that's
just horrible parenting in any other
world I don't think those would fly over
so smoothly all right kiddo I think
that's enough playing outside time to
come up in
[Music]
need a little help there okay oh you
were having a lot of fun out there
weren't you indeed but now it's time to
stop playing with your toys so alright
god my god Oh somebody's growing up okay
well why don't I make you a bowl of your
favorite Campbell soup I'll take that
yes there you go honey a bowl of your
favorite Oh
[Music]
well it's still classic in many people's
eyes and I think it's still gonna be for
quite a while longer
just don't try it home
[Music]
those are good at all but every once in
a while you come across a commercial
that's so ridiculous and so stupid you
swear to not even try like this one
I was just lazy here you go everyone's
seen this classic before of course it
was always sunny D which is good seeing
how the mother always buys a fucking wad
ton of them
how many varying sizes of that shit do
you need we got soda Oh J purple stuff
two kinds of Sunny D Oh the weird thing
about it is not that in every commercial
they always pick the Sunny D that's kind
of a no-brainer the weird thing is that
in every single commercial they push
aside the exact same drinks in precisely
the exact same order got soda OJ stuff
Flint some soda okay purple stuff we got
soda OJ purple stuff okay soda Oh J
purple stuff we got southern eyes Oh
James purple stuff we've got Oh J : some
purple stuff how can so many homes have
the exact same thing and so many kids
dismiss them in the exact same lineup
got soda OJ purple stuff maybe it's like
a cold like if we hear it enough times
we'll figure out it was the missing
combination too like that Stargate or
something
soda Oh J purple stuff and the missing
piece not funny tonight
take us to the world where the he-she
from The Crying Game will consume us all
I don't know what religious ritual you
started SunnyD but you need a little bit
more variety do none of these families
drink milk it sunny delighted the good
stuff kids go for unbearable stuff but
whatever reason the most intense toy
commercials in the late 80s and early
90s were laser tag guns it's like
they're in their own little epic sci-fi
movie like this one for example called
laser tag rocky let's go we're late for
our team the Owen Wilson whiners like
this
Jesus Christ we're done with this laser
tag being played
[Music]
that's right what's Y tres Jones's
called it there's no going back
what the hell was that I just got that
joke you told me ten minutes ago oh so
oh and Wicky are the last ones left this
is far too epic slow-mo that bitch so we
can enjoy it as long as possible
laser tag it's hotter than ever my god
that was incredible
an action that had suspense and then ha
and rookie laser tag rocky was literally
laser tag rocky who can compare with
that actually believe it or not this one
possibly could this was an ad for laser
pro 9000 it was a difficult day three
kids and fun and of course by kids we
naturally mean 30 year olds going
through some quarter life crisis we
admit it so there's two commercials
going on here there's actually a product
placement the product placement you
looking for something cold and the rest
of the commercial isn't tied to coke in
anyway it's not like coke presents laser
pro 9000 it's just kind of a strained
out of no or bit of Maine dropping which
is ironic seeing how they didn't exactly
say the name very well oh oh go Acco I
always talk like I'm on a trampoline we
will fight for our six pack of
artificial flavors and freedom so I'm
not gonna lie I'm just assuming this
future takes place in the same one that
crossfire does a future focused on the
revolution of a plastic triggered
uprising it's gonna change the world
look out monkeys two boxes
black-and-white tile diners to the
high-tech sports game of the nineties
laser pro 9000 yeah they made no sense
but for whatever reason these laser tag
commercials were fucking awesome laser
pro 9000 each sold separately of the
loop we're not a sound effect we're a
company what douche
I'm sorry I know that's unbelievably
immature but this is coming from a time
period when women's commercials didn't
talk about women's things they always
use kind of this codeword known as fresh
do you ever feel you know not so fresh
sometimes I just don't feel fresh my
best friend told me it's a real fresh
feeling fresh is a gentle breeze it's
natural to want to feel fresh but then
every once a while you just get a
commercial that jumps straight to the
point
like why do you can't buy any dish more
effective no more vinegar and water
dishes for me but when it comes to the
douche they use moved sure that's why I
do abs I go the next one up to child who
stay above us some receive the most
convenient disposable douche you can buy
[Music]
hey remember those commercials you swear
were from the 70s but were embarrassed
to find out they were made in your
decade Mentos was a candy that seemed to
solve every stupid problem with an even
stupider answer but because the jackass
had Mentos in his hands that apparently
made everything okay
I suppose it works you know everyone
remembers these ads but I just never got
how Mentos was the world peace of any
situation
[Music]
Mentos monteux's fuck me everything's
great why is this the answer to all of
life's problems
[Music]
tonight
nothing gets to you stay insane fool
with my possession
[Music]
Mentos the freshmaker what does it
matter you'll still be humming it and
that's what counts by getting away
scot-free with small crime that doesn't
hurt either
Mentos disrupt the system hey the
greatest family friendly system ever god
I remember when they used to make it
look like they could make your house Sol
or it could blast you out of your seat
or it could open up a world of
imagination you never thought possible
god I adored those whimsical commercials
so go ahead show us what's in store for
this one
[Music]
[Applause]
that's a dog why are you so scary now
[Music]
are you stealing my soul while I watch
you
[Music]
good God talk about commercial that got
everyone's attention this was the first
ad for the Macintosh and they depicted
in a creepy 1984 Orwellian future attila
wheedies commercial runs in to save the
day
On January 24 Apple computer will
introduce Macintosh and you'll see why
1984 won't be like 1984 yes Apple will
save us from the terrifying 1984 style
future for us we can clearly see today
no longer our people lined up like
cattle for hours and hours on end no
longer will people dress alike in cold
colourless environments no longer will
any cultish style groups gather together
to honor a grand controversial leader
and most importantly no longer will we
be brain dead lifeless zombies who plug
ourselves into the machine of life we
can also call the system Thank You Apple
you have done well
[Music]
good lord
we were really on this dictatorship test
don't be a kick for a while weren't we
what's this one selling there are places
where imagination is an outlaw where
freedom is feared where cookie boredom
rules and there are those who fight back
what there's someone who is brave enough
to stand up to cookie boredom don't you
know what you're risking yes they even
had cookies back then and as someone who
tried a box with them once and then
still seeing the doctor valid even to
this day you can imagine they weren't
very good but like I said before we were
so obsessed with ninja turtles that
literally all we needed was that first
note of the theme song in order to get
us horned it was pathetic but literally
every kid watching this said and this
looks pretty stupid and lame take my
money you play that one note we buy the
stuff we know how it works
nevertheless I think everybody has to
admit this is still a great commercial
for fighting off became a franchise that
was Neela's Lee everywhere
oh my god guy comes down bad man em were
threatening graphics than this I show
them turn that line the coop before
playing this I'm just gonna look at a
pop-up book for a minute
Jesus maybe the people in wolf of
wallstreet weren't even doing drawings
maybe they were just doing the Star Wars
Atari game the whole time I worked my
way from place to place I've got
everything I need right here with me
Star Wars
it's that good more big adventures damn
honeycomb yea-ah honeycomb the only
successful cereal that clearly had no
idea how to market itself program year
3000 right wanna lean on
we're gonna go search for an identity
I'm thinking Indiana Jones Star Wars
Battletoads and I guess a little Star
Wars getting the other guy really seem
to like it
[Music]
kids commercial guys Keith travursel
open your mouth and let paedophilia
jones do the rest of the work
can't beat the big taste of honeycomb
cereal well it does wash out the big
taste of something else big adventure in
every bite especially when the lights
are off and it's probably best if you
don't bite
a message from concerned children's
advertisers oh think our Canadian
commercial they'll calm us down from all
this open your mouth and close your eyes
controversy why do you think your mommy
or daddy are always telling you don't
put that in your mouth damn it Canada
don't you put it in your mouth don't
in your mouth don't you stop spit in
your face I'm faking your feet so it
might look good to you and Micah good to
eat and it might look good to pay and
they might look good today you could get
sick really you were looking for a word
to rhyme with sick and that's the best
one you could come up with in this
scenario don't you're probably in your
mouth tell you I do they have to look so
possessed while singing it too it just
doesn't add to the overall feel of the
experience
[Applause]
[Music]
just play y'all know what's coming it's
a rape whistle
Canada I make fun of you with this
because you have nothing else to make
father always ask someone you love
before you put anything in your mouth
except if that's something your mouth is
the person that you love thank you for
watching my commercial special tune in
next time
don't sometimes I just don't feel fresh
[Music]
you